shelter joined us again with more of her
exclusive interview with Kim Richards
yeah you know guys we have seen a lot of
Kim's wildlife play out on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills we've seen
the cat fighting the drink throwing it
got really really crazy so you have to
wonder will Kim go back to the show and
what does she really think about her
cast mates well I found out you want to
threaten me you want to go there let's
do I'm telling you a lot thank you they
got scary voice mistreat and bring years
of your relationship with your sister do
you think the show has hurt your
relationship yeah it has how's your
relationship with Kyle we're talking are
you talking that's really good to hear
because when we last saw at the end of
the reunion it was a tough spot you
aren't mean Kim told me she's talked to
her sister a few times since then
but the explosive exchange between Kim
and fellow housewife Lisa Rinna last
season pushed them over the edge
okay stop I'm gonna defend your behavior
when you act like this what are you
talking about Kyle and Lisa were spotted
out together in the 90210 yesterday
shooting for the show's new season the
ladies were all smiles but there's no
love lost between Kim and Lisa about
Lisa Rinna we had made up at that final
party she texted me two days after the
final party and I got these messages I
mean who buys it's like be very careful
or I will and I was like huh but this is
days effort or were finished these
messages kept coming no more filming
this is not for the show I got scared
I called a bodyguard who's a police
officer I said what do I need to do he
said you need to file a police report if
I say Lisa Vanderpump what do you think
I think Lisa has a very she's witty
she's fun she has a big heart for people
she loves you've described her before as
a manipulator she's
nice meeting something so will Kim be
back for another round of housewives at
times it was fun we did fun things and
other days it was just completely
stressful it sounds like you're speaking
in the past tense are you done with
housewives they have asked me to come
back you haven't made up your mind I
just came home some treatment I'm still
focusing on my sobriety we haven't
talked yet so so what I should say